don't see what hans has in mind and the
fact that he's paused to think okay this
is the current position the fact that
han's paws there means that uh he is
unsure as well he's a bit nervous about
what is to come
so magnus he's got a choice of this pawn
this pawn or a safe move just maybe
moving his queen
all right magnus carlsen is in the move
and again we hear the rain pouring on
the roof here in the studio in oslo so
let's uh get away from this awful
weather in oslo and head to the
beautiful weather in miami i hear rumors
about 36 degrees celsius sweater
[Music]
yeah that's the time when you want to
bring a jacket and really
feel this weather outside it's so humid
you can't even begin to believe it but i
have something to cool me down because i
have one of the coolest gms there is
right now alejandra ramirez you are here
in miami what are you doing here now
well i'm here as a spectator this is one
of the best events that happened in
america in a very long time outside of
st louis so i couldn't miss it i'm happy
to be here the fact that it's warm and
beautiful miami well